for one week every summer since 1951 an
extraordinary meeting between Nobel
laureates and young researchers has
taken place on Lindo Island in Germany
they meet to exchange ideas and discuss
fresh challenges in different fields of
research in 2009 the field was chemistry
and the lindau meetings proved a potent
catalyst how many times in a lifetime of
a student does he have an opportunity to
meet 20 30 40 50 Nobel laureates and to
ask them whatever is on their heart I
mean this was my dream as a kid and here
all of a sudden you can see that the
Linda Foundation can make this dream
proof talking to professor chicken Nova
was really fascinating to me it was
great that he wanted to hear what I'm
doing and you have anything in mind
yes something in mind the subject will
be a human protease which might be
involved in Alzheimer's disease he was
definitely interested in the correlation
of my work and Alzheimer's disease and
maybe he also learned from something
from that yeah I did learn something new
he told me about a protease in the brain
that is active in dissolving aggregates
in Alzheimer disease yes indeed I did
learn I read a lot on the disease but I
must admit I was blind to this process
completely it's one of the best
organized but also it's the largest
number of students and from all over the
world so I suppose is the one place in
the world you occasionally seem like a
rock star but he's famous for working on
these soccer ball molecules called
fullerene or C 60 also known as a
buckyball so C 60 is so great because
it's 60 carbon atoms put together into
such a spectacular structure
it's incredibly stable and it looks like
a soccer ball of course all new
technologies which are powerful will
have possible damaging effects and I
like to now stand back from this problem
and say well let's now go back a hundred
years what are the dangers of chemistry
there are several we could predict
there's going to be something like the
lid of my tragedy there's a possibility
of nerve gases so okay we're not going
to do any chemistry now from 1909 for
the rest of forever well we wouldn't
have the modern world this is my third
time at lindau this is the only official
Nobel sanctioned meeting of laureates
outside of Stockholm well how are things
going for you here and then Dow is this
what you expected it's even more than I
expected it it's very unusual for us to
get Nobel laureates coming to Australia
so to be in a place where 23 of them
have come is just very special and
wouldn't give this opportunity up for
the world so you discovered aquaporins
which let the water in and out of the
cell how important is that do you like
to drink beer I do next time you're on
an airliner and you've had two beers
your bladder is full and the seatbelt
light goes on
ask yourself how important are the
aquaporins so important the diffusion of
water across membranes into cells and
other cells it occurs in all tissues but
there are some tissues where water
transport occurs really rapidly I think
most people my age will say well we're
the present or the past of science but
they're the future and that that's
irresistible
the lectures from the laureates have
surpassed my expectations I think most
of them are very eloquent speakers it
explains the whole of chemistry all the
biology all of life and all the useful
bits of physics if any so it's nice to
come to a meeting where you're not bored
so one thing that I as a young scientist
I still have choices to make as far as
what I want to specialize in and
deciding between which techniques to try
and like master or use and as a student
well if I heard right that you were
learning to play the cello and that
indicates that you are interested in
something that involves real time
performance some scientists like sort of
live observation I feel extremely
privileged to be able to meet this
year's Nobel Prize winner especially
because he's in a field that's very
relevant to what I'm doing one of the
things I like the bat type of imaging if
you understand experiment you can watch
the cell on the live TV screen doing
something and you actually have to react
to them it's a conversation you're
having with the self the first time I
got to go into the lab and do a single
molecule experiment and that when you
see this you know blip and you know that
that's from most likely a single
molecule then I certainly that something
that's still like gratifying and well
then then I think maybe you're you're a
goner for this type of experiment and
maybe this is what you want to do for
your life
Lindau seems to be this really special
place it seems like a place that is
going to really facilitate the kind of
discussions and the kind of scientific
development that are going to lead me to
future collaborations which is something
I'm really excited about do I see
something of myself in them yeah of
course I mean I was young once believe
it or not and if I can learn something
from them get inspiration learn where
they get their inspiration from that it
would be fantastic so right now I'm
working on photo patterning polymer
surfaces so what are you gonna do with
all the surface stuff that you're doing
now I mean if you good question
I mean the possibility of a number of
different applications really gets me
excited you can imagine sticking just
about anything on to the surface if you
have a universal enough method and so we
should be able to stick
proteins on two surfaces DNA on two
surfaces metal nanoparticles on two
surfaces so really at that point it's
only your imagination that asked to ask
the question well what kind of molecule
do I want to put on to the surface it's
it's like you mentioned you know you
take a surface you put a clickable group
on it you click on a fan or something
yeah I think I pitched a collaboration
to him which hopefully he'll take me up
on I give him my card so we'll see and
this year with an important United
Nations meeting about the world's
climate approaching in Copenhagen
climate change was also a theme at the
lindau meeting and nature's olive
Heffernan was there what we know now is
the climate is changing at an
unprecedented rate and scientists say
that we're to blame so what can we do
about it
we need everybody on this planet all
countries on this planet
by the year 2050 have reduced carbon
dioxide emissions by 80 percent over the
past week I've met some of the best
minds in science who are turning their
attention to this problem joining me
have been three young enthusiastic
researchers all working on various
aspects of climate change and wondering
what they can do to solve the problem
are the people going to be able to meet
this problem and you know just face the
fact that energy is no longer going to
be cheap the developing countries they
have other priorities should the
developed world take the lead well
firstly I agree with you I think the
developed nations who have to take the
first step
what are your ideas on how we implement
education and policy the information and
education is an absolutely essential
part of going to the path of reducing
emissions and the reduction of the
emissions starts with every individual
at home the problem is that over the
long haul we don't seem to be able to
find a way to stop using fossil fuels I
don't want to buy inefficient
technologies I want to pay you to make
much more efficient solar panels if you
could come up with solar panels that
would be cheaper than fossil fuels we'd
be done when I was a kid and fell in
love with biology and it was early on
and then along the years the nobel prize
was something in the seventh haven in
meeting a Nobel laureate I thought that
these creatures have horns and four eyes
and their huge brains it was it a dream
never to be materialized
so the meeting with them on one hand
shows them that these are just human
being and it's all doable they can do it
you